be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so due to the Netflix announcement of a
she-hulk series after the completion of
the defenders what I want to do here is
have a discussion about she-hulk and
what I'm hoping is that at the end of
all this you'll have a strong
understanding of her character as well
as how she's evolved over the years
so Jennifer Walters first appeared in
savage she-hulk issue number one in 1980
and was created by Stan Lee and John
Buscema
however unlike most of novel's lineup
she-hulk did not originate with a comic
book landscape instead she came as a
result of the television show The
Incredible Hulk starring Bill Bixby as
banner and Lou Ferrigno as the Hulk and
an article by Britain's Sunday Times
titled 70 things you didn't know about
Marvel the creation of she-hulk
originated in the idea that Universal
television had planned to make a
spin-off of The Hulk using a female
version of the character looking to both
boost the popularity of the show and
secure the rights themselves however
with model getting wind of this Stan Lee
was tasked with writing the first issue
of she-hulk securing the rights in the
process and forcing Universal to go
forward without she-hulk on the
television show that said in her
original appearance as it was written by
Stan Lee Jennifer Walters is the
daughter of a man named sheriff Walters
and a woman named Elaine banner Walters
but is also the cousin of Bruce Banner
and growing up together Bruce and
Jennifer developed a brother and sister
like bond but once they reached
adulthood they eventually went their
separate ways
as both pursue different careers in life
while banner would find himself immersed
in the realm of physics jennifer
attended the UCLA School of Law where
she became one of the top legal scholars
earning her master's degree in Harvard
Law School and becoming a lawyer now
because this era in Marvel Comics saw
banners identity as the Hulk kept secret
from the larger Marvel landscape after
reconnecting with Jennifer following
their time apart the closeness between
the two was immediately established with
banners sharing the secret of being
Incredible Hulk wanting to talk more in
private they had decided to leave her
office so no one could overhear their
conversation
however with Jennifer's role as an
attorney seeing her coming into conflict
with various entities in the criminal
underworld
unbeknownst to herself or banner the two
were actually being tailed by the crime
boss Nicholas Trask who had once been an
enemy of Jennifer's father and one of
her current clients hiring two hit men
to assassinate Jennifer in an effort to
enter investigations into the criminal
acts during their journey the hit
and headshot Jennifer seriously winning
her in the process acting quickly due to
realize in the medical attention would
arrive too late
banner was able to escape taking
Jennifer to a doctor's office himself to
this end realizing that Jennifer had
lost too much blood from the gunshot
wound and needed a blood transfusion
since there were no other donors of her
type immediately available manner used
his own gamma-irradiated blood for the
transfusion as a result once the process
was complete and Jennifer was in stable
condition banner had immediately left
under the belief that Jennifer would be
safe during which time traps hitmen
returned
posing as doctors in an effort to ensure
Jennifer's death discovering her room
and attempting to carry out the
assassination because a whole
transformation occurs in a state of
heightened adrenaline as a result of
anger with her life in jeopardy fear
overtook Jennifer leading to her first
transformation catching the men by
surprise chasing him out of the hospital
and forcing a confession in front of the
police following this and with her
adrenaline returning to normal states
Jennifer returned to her normal form
traveled back to the hospital and
re-entered her bed leaving the hospital
staff unaware of her transformation
during which time she vowed that the
whole persona would return to solve any
of the problems Jennifer Walters could
not now following this initial
introduction because the Incredible Hulk
had been such a popular character
especially among college students with
the early 1980s seeing the rise of
second wave feminism Jennifer's time as
she hook saw a multitude of changes in
the early days of her solo publications
much like Bruce Banner
Jennifer was unable to control the
she-hulk transformation and at one point
even had mental blocks placed on herself
to keep the transformation from
happening while this standard was
popular in that she-hulk had her own
adventures but was seemingly identical
to the Incredible Hulk albeit weaker in
terms of strength the demands of second
wave feminism led to Marvel offering
small changes to her character allowing
she-hulk to step into her own while
maintaining the root of her popularity
and The Incredible Hulk concept coming
under the control of David Anthony Kraft
with issue number two because crafts
time as writer of the defenders in the
1970s focus on themes like temptations
of power the Cold War and the subsequent
nuclear arms race these themes were
combined with his experience creating
children's stories allowing for a soft
transition to she hope being elevated to
a more serious character while
maintaining some of light hearted
standards
by Stanley to this end the early issues
of crafts run focused heavily on the
difficulty of Jennifer balancing her
life as a heroic she-hulk
whether life is a lawyer where many of
the stories went hand in hand allowing
her to investigate criminals inner hope
form while bringing them to justice as a
lawyer on the home one of the major
issues faced by prospective female
readers was the she-hulk was essentially
a copy of Bruce looking to eliminate
this major obstacle and allow Jennifer
to move away from the shadow of her
cousin Kraft initiated an unofficial
four-part series with issues 9 through
12 focusing on Jennifer developing a
blood disease contacting Reed Richards
who in turn introduced her to a man
named Daniel Ridge Daniel's experience
with blood diseases led to a
consultation with Michael Morbius
allowing Jennifer to make contact and an
effort to seek a cure at a sidetrack
here as a classic spider-man villain
known more through appearance than by
his name Michael Morbius is likely the
most knowledgeable person in the world
when it comes to blood diseases due to
the fact that he himself had suffered
from a condition of this sort and was
transformed into a vampire
during his attempts to find a cure as a
result his survival hinged on his
ability to locate and consume blood
requiring that he analyze all types
including those most conducive to his
survival efficiently taking place in
issues 11 and 12 with she-hulk on the
verge of dying from her disease the
intervention of Daniel Ridge and Michael
Morbius came with a serum designed for
Morbius himself but given to Jennifer
eliminating the issue of anger based
transformations and allowing her to
shift between the she-hulk and Jennifer
Walter identities at will albeit with
physical pain furthermore Regina for
herself had viewed the she-hulk persona
as something akin to a curse with the
newfound control over her
transformations craft established that
because Jennifer did not suffer from the
same childhood trauma and abuse as her
cousin Banner instead of shunning or
living in fear of the hope form Jennifer
actually embraced it allowing her to
view the she-hulk persona as a
confidence builder as a result and
throughout crafts run pollen or cure the
idea of a dual persona
began to take a backseat with Jennifer
preferring to remain in the she-hulk
form instead of being Jennifer Walters
never crafts run lasted for 25 issues
between 1980 and 1982 because Jim
shooter had been elevated to the
position of editor-in-chief where he had
maintained such a strict editorial
control
Marvel Comics enforcing deadlines and
maintaining continuity his actions
alienated a number of longtime writers
and artists who vacated their positions
turning to competitors like DC or other
creator own publication houses at the
same time with savage she-hulk failing
to achieve the same financial success as
The Incredible Hulk and other Marvel
related titles in addition to David
Anthony Kraft a parting his writer that
savage she-hulk line was cancelled
leading to subsequent appearances and
Avengers in a sidetrack for a second
because the Avengers team was a mishmash
of heroes who were either unable to
carry their own titles were being
exposed to the reader base in an effort
to gauge fan reception or simply always
been a part of the team with she halt
being unable to maintain her own title
it actually made perfect sense to roll
her over onto the Avengers in addition
to this because this time period saw Jim
shooter launching the original Secret
Wars event and the introduction of the
original Beyonder where the story had a
multitude of themes coming out of his
conclusion including the breakup of
Kitty Pryde and Colossus spider-man
gaining the Venom symbiote and the
introduction of Julia carpenter as
Spider Woman one of the major
developments came in the form of models
experimentation on replacing Ben Grimm
as the muscle of the Fantastic Four
introducing she-hulk into their ranks
and truth this time period of her career
saw massive success for her character
due to the team still standing as
Marvel's first family with John Byrne in
control of the title during his
legendary run between issues 232 and 295
while his career following the end of
the Fantastic run was focused on
developing Superman for DC Comics and
the post-crisis on Infinite Earths
continuity the popularity of she-hulk
and Byrnes returned to Marvel led to a
second volume in 1989 titled the
sensational she-hulk running for 60
issues with John Byrne involved in
issues one through eight and thirty one
through 15 unlike her previous
depictions which were more serious - a
couple of exceptions Byrnes time on the
title was almost completely comedic
satirising comic books Andrews and she
hoaxes awareness as she was actually a
comic book character as an example in
the first eight issues Jennifer became
an assistant district attorney and began
working for New York City District
Attorney Blake tower during this time
she had met Lewis Mason formerly the
Golden Age superhero in the blonde
phantom and he got a long series of
unusual encounters where she battled dr.
bong Zima the Titan Nick st. Christopher
and Sprague the living comet
however the fourth
all element of her character came into
play when she hug discovered that Lewis
Mason had manipulated tower into hiring
Jennifer so that Mason might again start
in a comic book and thus avoid dying of
old age due to the fact that comic book
characters never aged as a result
she-hulk had vacated her position taking
up work as a lawyer with us for hire
eventually leading to a relationship
between herself and Luke Cage now in
addition to her own solo adventures and
breaking the fourth wall on the front
cover of the sensational she-hulk comics
and never to keep her exposed to the
larger marvel reader base John Byrne
orchestrated a number of guest
appearances and crossovers including the
two issued limited series the she-hulk
ceremony written by Dwayne McDuffie and
focusing on the revelation of Jennifer's
affection for Wyatt Wingfoot a close
friend of the Fantastic Four Black
Panther and the Inhumans now her burns
run ended with issue number 60 and 1994
and the cancellation of the sensational
she-hulk title between 1994 and 2002 she
hooked herself continue to make backup
one-shot and team appearances and
Franklin Richards Fantastic force by Tom
Brevoort doc Samson's 1996 miniseries by
Dan Slott Heroes for Hire by John
Ostrander and the Avengers however with
writer Joe Quesada becoming editor in
chief in 2000 because his mindset was
similar to Jim shooter and that he
preferred emphasis on eliminating
unsuccessful characters and titles and
introducing new content as part of the
lead-up to house of M decimation and
civil war Marvel launched Avengers
disassembled under writer Brian Michael
Bendis centering on the Scarlet Witch
becoming convinced that the Avengers had
kidnapped her non-existent children
Wanda had waged war against them using
various members to her own ends
including manipulating Tony Stark's mind
to appear drunk in front of the United
Nations leading to a conflict at
Avengers mansion during this time
she-hulk was hexed by Wanda sending
Jennifer into a rage almost identical to
banner savage hoped form where she
rampaged throughout the streets while
the rest of the Avengers disassembled
would see Wanda manifesting a Kree
Armada the death of Hawkeye and the
Avengers disbanding because she hope had
been subdued as part of the events
leading up to the discovery that Wanda
was behind the attacks following the
conclusion of both Avengers disassembled
in house of M the she-hulk series was
relaunched as vol 2
dance lot it's part of the lead-up to
Civil War to sidetrack here because the
main civil war conflict existed as a
battle centering on the opposing
positions of Captain America and Iron
Man with both Thor and banner having
been removed from the landscape in Thor
disassembled and Planet Hulk
respectively while Jennifer was not as
strong as her cousin her physical
strength was enough to turn the tide if
use in the beginning of the story in an
effort to solve this equation both Dan
Slott and Mark Miller looked to the
pages of she-hulk second series and
Civil War itself to establish that
Jennifer's rampage had driven her to
remain in her human form at a field over
her actions as a result she had no major
role within the battles of Civil War and
instead elected to register while
simultaneously operating as a lawyer
providing counsel for heroes and
villains looking for legal means to
avoid registration net said where she
did have a role in the final conflict of
Civil War itself on the whole she-hulk
had never quite achieved a high level of
success instead her position within
Marvel stood in more of a supportive
capacity appearing in World War Hulk
secret invasion Dark Reign and his part
of the Lady liberators an all-female
team composed of Jennifer Walters as
leader alongside Susan storm Valkyrie
Thundra Spider Woman
Tigra Black Widow and Hellcat
furthermore with Jonathan Pigman writing
the Fantastic Four and forming the
future foundation as an organization
designed to serve the veteran of mankind
the idea of she-hulk existing as a
member of the team was revisited when
she alongside Peter Parker were added to
the roster in a support capacity an
addition to this where she was part of
the incredible hulks the MIAA and
fearsome force storylines and 2014 as
part of the Marvel now event this
she-hulk title was launched as a third
volume under the writing of Charles
Soule receiving critical acclaim for
both the story and art with some placing
it on the same level as mad fractions
run on Hawkeye fan reception at Charles
Soule she-hulk was huge in that the
story centered on Jennifer as a strong
confident woman and capable lawyer an
aspect of Seoul's storytelling that
resonated with fans while the series was
canceled after only 12 issues in a post
on his personal blog Charles Soule had
stated that was sales functioning as one
half of the reason model had also been
leading up to Secret Wars which resulted
in the action of all existing solo
series whether that be abruptly as was
the case with she-hulk or gradual
phase-out in the form of last days
which was seen in the Loki and Miss
Marvel series culminating in the
destruction of the multiverse during
Hickman's run on Avengers and New
Avengers with the start of Secret Wars
and the launch of its tie-ins writers G
willow Wilson and Margaret Bennett were
brought on board to launch a force
centering on an all-female team not
unlike the lady liberators but composed
of summer models top-tier heroines
including Dazzler America Chavez Medusa
and crystal of the Inhumans a force was
critically praised for storytelling and
art providing readers with a team that
didn't feel like a ploy towards feminism
and instead provided strong women
playing strong roles leading to the
launch of all-new all-different marvel
because the a force miniseries was so
well received when the model prime
universe was created by Reed Richards
molecule man and Franklin Richards a
force returned with a similar roster
than what was found within Secret Wars
consisting of she-hulk Carol Danvers
Medusa singularity Dazzler and Nico
Minoru with it being released in January
of 2016 with G willow Wilson returning
his lighter much like the team from
Secret Wars a force function as a woman
centric group facing threats from both
within the earth and beyond now where we
are only five issues in and I will have
a video on the team proper on the whole
a force has maintained the popularity of
its original miniseries providing a
combination of everyday struggles and
heroics giving readers of view of the
teams members on a personal level
developing them further than the stories
found within their own past comics with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and let me know how
you guys feel about she-hulk I'm curious
and I will catch you guys later please